So counting let's us think about quantities
of objects and answer questions about
them, whether it's how many students are
in a teacher's class or how many moons
orbit Saturn. Now, usually, when we count,
we start with the number one and then we
get to two, and three, four, and so on so
forth. And we could keep counting like
that until we get to huge numbers, like
1,000 or 1 million or 1 trillion, and even
then, we could still keep going. Now, this
special set of numbers has a name, they
are called the natural numbers. So the
natural numbers start with one and
increase by ones forever. So now we want
to make sure that you're totally solid on
what falls under this category. Which of
these numbers are natural numbers, 735, 6,
89.1, -1,000, 1/3, and 19? This is a
slightly different kind of than then the
last one. This time I want you to check
off all of the answers that you think are
right. So that might mean checking more
than one, in some cases, you might even
check off all of the answers that are
there.